how to balance work with relaxation
i got a great question from one of my
newsletter readers jacob who wrote in to
say
hey evan it seems like you have a strong
type a personality
a real achiever who works hard probably
sacrifices social life relaxation for
work study
like me i feel like a lot of people that
i'm around don't really understand this
personality type
it sometimes leaves me discouraged if
you ever felt this way
do you have any personal advice to
embracing this personality type
or balancing work with relaxation thanks
for doing what you do
bro thank you jacob this is a great
question
i don't know if i've got it all figured
out uh you know you ask me a business
question i'm more online but but let me
answer the best way that i know how okay
uh
i find that for me to be happy i need
my own personal time to relax and do my
own thing
i need family time and then i need
my business time and if any of those
gets too out of whack i
i get unhappy so if i'm spending too
much time in my business
and i don't have my family time or
personal alone time that then i feel
like i need i need that break
you know if i'm on vacation and we're
just sitting there on a beach
i get fidgety i get agitated i want to i
have to think about business you know i
miss my business
too much or if i'm alone too much and i
miss the other thing so there has to be
a balance for me and there's a range
you know it's not like the same amount i
need 10 hours of family time or whatever
it is
uh but there's a range and i start to i
have to listen to
i guess my body myself and figure out
when something is too far out of whack i
gotta change it
what i would say is it's important for
the the main person in your life so i
don't know if you're married of a
girlfriend or whatever
that person has to be understanding and
feel kind of the
the same way as you do it has to be
understanding of your personality and
support what you're doing
from you know relationships that i've
seen typically if you're the strong type
a
personality usually your partner
isn't right because if you are both
strong type a personalities you're
always fighting
uh i you know i'm not the relationship
expert so i'm sure there's more
qualified people to talk about that but
but
you know i believe the person that
you're with your
life partner should be somebody who
supports
what you're doing and fits well with
your personality otherwise you're in
for a lifetime of fighting what i found
helps me in terms of the people so
you're asking about surrounding yourself
with people who
support you i have two groups of friends
and there's very little overlap between
them i have one group of friends that
are my entrepreneur friends
and and we meet up we talk about
business we're we're goal oriented we're
focused we're driven we're let's go
achieve this you know let's do something
great
and i have a group of i call mastermind
group we meet every
every month there's two groups and and
we sit down we push each other be better
be stronger do something amazing
uh rah-rah-rah you know like getting the
blood pumping
uh massive achievement that's your type
a
you know action right there and then i
have my other group of friends that are
salsa friends
and i'll spend like 20 hours a week in
the salsa community dancing djing
teaching sometimes uh and salsa people
are the exact opposite at least
here they're can i say lazier they're
lazier
they're not as responsible they
are more chill laid back don't show up
to things on time
which is the complete opposite of my
entrepreneur friends
and so i balance it you know
some weeks i'm spending a lot more time
doing salsa
when i just need a break i need to relax
i don't want to think about all the
craziness that that is the business
and i'll hang out with those people the
salsa people who
just you know just fun time uh and relax
and then you know if i'm feeling too
relaxed
and i need to go do something i need
some energy
i'll go hang out with my entrepreneur
friends and and we'll talk business and
we'll get excited and we'll help each
other's companies and we'll get new
things that we can
even if i'm talking about it i'm
speaking faster i'm more energetic
and so i think you need to balance those
out and
you know you have to find whatever ratio
works for you
you know the people you surround
yourself with you have a choice these
are your friends you have a choice of
who you hang out with
it sounds like you have a lot of the
people who are the chill laid back
kind of people so you have that covered
off you may want to find people who are
more ambitious
ready to go you know drive
drive our goal forward make things
happen kind of people
and you can either form your own group
or or look for an existing group to join
uh because getting that other group to
kind of motivate you and surround
yourself with will help you
cover off that side of your personality
and then when you're ready to chill and
relax you have your other friends to
help you out too
anyway that's what works for me
hopefully that helped you jacob great
question for those of you watching you
like the video
give it a thumbs up below let me know
what you think how do you handle that
question
how do you balance your work and your
leisure activities leave a comment
below you have a question for me leave
it below too i'll make a video response
just like this
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel see more videos like this
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it and i'll see you soon
you